[Música]
Hola hoy en sciencelich la teoría de
cuerdas
nuestro universo contiene materia que al
agrandar la escala lo suficiente está
formada por partículas existen
diferentes tipos de partículas
electrones quarks y neutrinos
las partículas se mueven y pueden
interactuar mediante intercambio de
otras partículas la fuerza
electromagnética por ejemplo es
transportada por el intercambio de
fotones
todas estas partículas diferentes
conforman lo que se conoce como el
modelo estándar nuestra descripción
matemática más precisa del mundo
cuántico hasta la fecha
Existen dos categorías principales de
partículas los fermiones que conforman
la materia y los buzones que contribuyen
a la descripción de las interacciones
a primera vista se podría pensar que se
trata de la teoría final que el modelo
estándar puede describirlo todo Pero por
desgracia hay otra interacción que
escapa a este modelo la gravitación
al Gran escala la gravitación puede
describirse mediante la relatividad
general los astros curvan el
espacio-tiempo lo que atrae a otros
astros
como ocurre con otros tipos de
interacciones cabría esperar que la
curvatura del espacio-tiempo estuviese
compuestas cada cuántica de pequeñas
partículas Cuántas de curvatura del
espacio-tiempo llamadas gravitones
[Música]
pero cuando se intenta incluir el
gravitón en el modelo estándar los
cálculos dan resultados absurdos con
valores infinitos que no se pueden
remediar nada que hacer no hemos
conseguido describir la gravedad a
escala cuántica
para resolver este problema los físicos
llevan más de medio siglo buscando
nuevas teorías en este vídeo
construiremos juntos uno de los enfoques
más prometedores la teoría de cuerdas
[Música]
la idea fundamental es bastante sencilla
en el modelo estándar las partículas se
describen como pequeños puntos sin
dimensión se presupone que estos puntos
no tienen todos las mismas propiedades
lo que explica que existan diferentes
tipos de partículas
en la teoría de cuerdas supondremos que
en realidad si nos acercamos a las
partículas Todas están formadas por el
mismo objeto una pequeña cuerda a veces
abierta a veces cerrada
estas pequeñas cuerdas tienen tensión
como diminutos elásticos y pueden vibrar
una cuerda de guitarra puede vibrar de
diferentes maneras los armónicos
del mismo modo las pequeñas cuerdas
pueden vibrar de diferentes formas una
ondulación dos ondulaciones tres
ondulaciones en fin
y cada forma de vibrar se comporta a
nuestra escala como una partícula
diferente
al hacer los cálculos se descubre que
algunas cuerdas se comportarían como
fotones
[Música]
Y aún mejor algunas como gravitones
partiendo del sencillo principio de que
las partículas son pequeñas Cuerdas con
una tensión se explica ya Por qué hay
distintos tipos de partículas
[Música]
Y de forma natural predecimos la
existencia de gravitón describiendo la
gravedad a escala cuántica
ahora queremos comprender cómo
evolucionan estas cuerdas en el universo
para ello nos basaremos en los
principios de nuestros modelos actuales
imaginemos que lanzamos un electrón
contra un objeto el electrón se propaga
como una onda y al llegar al objeto es
imposible predecir por adelantado la
posición en la que se materializará
a la escala de las partículas un mismo
experimento puede dar varios resultados
diferentes
solo se puede predecir la probabilidad
de observar este o aquel resultado y el
objetivo de la física Es establecer
estas probabilidades
el enfoque matemático para determinar la
probabilidad de observar un resultado
consiste en considerar al mismo tiempo
todos los escenarios posibles que
conducen a ese resultado se suman todas
las trayectorias pero también todas las
interacciones posibles por ejemplo un
electrón puede emitir un fotón y luego
reabsorberlo o dos fotones o incluso
tres
en todos los escenarios que contamos
decidimos manualmente autorizar cierto
tipo de interacciones para reproducir lo
que observamos en la realidad
al sumar todos estos escenarios
obtenemos la probabilidad deseada
en la teoría de cuerdas el planteamiento
es el mismo pero en vez de puntos las
partículas son cuerdas
un punto tras una trayectoria en el
tiempo pero una cuerda traza una
superficie
y para describir la evolución de una
cuerda de forma probabilística tendremos
en cuenta todas las geometrías posibles
que puede trazar a lo largo del tiempo
puede seguir una trayectoria en
particular
vibrar de una cierta manera
pero también dividirse Lo que equivale a
emitir una partícula o recombinarse Lo
que equivale a reabsorber una partícula
formando una geometría con un agujero
al contar todas las geometrías posibles
incluimos automáticamente las
interacciones a la teoría de cuerdas ya
no es necesario hacerlo manualmente
además las interacciones en el modelo
estándar son locales la emisión de un
fotón por ejemplo es instantánea
pero en la teoría de cuerdas las
interacciones son ahora continuas la
partícula no se emite instantáneamente
sino progresivamente
esto evita los valores infinitos y
absurdos que se obtienen cuando se
intenta incluir el gravitón en el modelo
estándar
así la teoría de cuerdas no solo predice
la existencia del gravitón sino que
también nos permite comprender cómo
interactúa con otras partículas y por
tanto describir la gravedad cuántica
[Música]
hasta ahora la teoría parece muy
prometedora explica Por qué hay
diferentes tipos de partículas
predice si pueden interactuar
e incluye una descripción cuántica de la
gravedad
pero desgraciadamente a estas alturas el
modelo Tiene tres problemas
primer problema todas las cuerdas se
comportan como buzones al igual que el
fotón o el gravitón
en realidad existe otro tipo de
partículas los fermiones como los
electrones o los quarks pero por el
momento nuestro modelo no los predice
el segundo problema consiste en la
predicción de una partícula llamada
taquión su masa Parece ser un número
imaginario raíz cuadrada de un número
negativo se trata de un sin sentido un
problema matemático que debe ser
eliminado
[Música]
Por último el tercer problema nuestro
espacio tiempo tiene cuatro dimensiones
tres de espacio y una de tiempo pero
esta teoría solo parece funcionar en un
Universo de 26 dimensiones en este punto
la teoría de cuerdas parece estar muy
lejos de describir correctamente nuestro
universo
para remediar estos problemas llevaremos
la teoría un poco más lejos para incluir
fermiones en nuestro modelo La idea es
Añadir espinores a las cuerdas Este es
el ingrediente matemático que ya se
utiliza para escribir los fermiones en
el modelo estándar este único aporte
Añadir espinores a las cuerdas resuelve
dos problemas el modelo predice ahora la
existencia de fermiones y ya no predice
la existencia del taquión la supuesta
partícula problemática
esta teoría más completa se denomina
teoría de las súper cuerdas de hecho
ahora que se han añadido los pinores la
teoría tiene una simetría fundamental
entre fermiones y bosones
en cierto modo predice que habría tantos
buzones como fermiones es lo que se
denomina supersimetría
y el tercer problema antes de incluir la
supersimetría las matemáticas exigían un
Universo de 26 dimensiones ahora bien la
teoría es supercuerdas requiere un
Universo de 10 dimensiones nueve de
espacio y una de tiempo
este tercer problema no está resuelto de
nuevo la teoría no parece ajustarse a
nuestro Universo de tan solo cuatro
dimensiones
sin embargo hasta ahora el modelo
parecía muy prometedor debemos Entonces
abandonarlo si existiesen dónde estarían
las seis dimensiones faltantes
una posibilidad es que nuestro universo
sea solo una porción tridimensional de
un súper universo mayor de nueve
dimensiones
[Música]
otra posibilidad es que las 9
dimensiones que no observamos estén
enrolladas sobre sí mismas
para entenderlo mejor imaginemos una
hormiga moviéndose sobre una pajita
esta tiene dos dimensiones la hormiga
puede caminar hacia adelante hacia atrás
y de izquierda a derecha alrededor de
ella
pero si uno se aleja lo suficiente solo
se puede ver una de las dos dimensiones
la segunda dimensión que circunda la
pajita es muy pequeña por lo que no
puede verse a esta escala
[Música]
en la teoría de cuerdas podemos imaginar
un fenómeno análogo nuestro universo
tendría nueve dimensiones del espacio
pero seis de ellas serían dimensiones
muy pequeñas enroscadas sobre sí mismas
de modo que no podemos verlas a nuestra
escala esta hipótesis puede parecer un
tanto discutible es razonable suponer la
existencia de dimensiones que no
observamos
no obstante resulta que la existencia de
dimensiones adicionales es una cuestión
muy interesante que plantea fenómenos
que sí podríamos observar por ejemplo
podemos imaginar una partícula sin masa
que se mueva la velocidad de la luz pero
parcialmente dentro de una dimensión
compacta
desde nuestro punto de vista no
percibiríamos esta dimensión y en
consecuencia la partícula nos parecería
más lenta solo observaríamos una parte
de su movimiento total a nuestra escala
parecería ralentizado como si tuviera
masa
la idea de dimensiones extra compactas
propone así un mecanismo bastante simple
por el que algunas partículas podrían
manifestarse con una masa muy grande
sin embargo por el momento requerirían
demasiada energía para crearlas en
nuestros aceleradores de partículas y
verificar su existencia o no
la presencia de estas seis dimensiones
extra en la teoría de cuerdas admite
también una gama mucho más amplia de
modos vibracionales y por tanto
indirectamente una mayor diversidad de
partículas posibles
además existen multitud de formas
diferentes de colapsar seis dimensiones
y cada posibilidad se traduce por un
universo diferente en cada tipo de
universo las cuerdas pueden adoptar
diferentes modos de vibración y por
tanto comportarse como partículas
diferentes
al elegir con precisión Cómo se
compactan las seis dimensiones podemos
afinar nuestra descripción para predecir
las mismas partículas que observamos en
la realidad
[Música]
sin embargo entre la mirada de
posibilidades aún no está claro por qué
nuestro universo contiene las partículas
del modelo estándar en lugar de otras
posibilidades
según algunas hipótesis aún
especulativas la geometría del universo
podría incluso haber variado con el
tiempo pasando de una forma de compactar
las seis dimensiones a otra y las leyes
de la física podrían entonces haber
cambiado Durante los primeros instantes
del Big Bang
En conclusión la teoría de cuerdas sigue
siendo especulativa y muy difícil de
verificar experimentalmente ya que las
cuerdas serían increíblemente diminutas
y es solo un enfoque entre muchos otros
para intentar llegar a la teoría
definitiva
sin embargo es uno de los modelos más
prometedores cuyos frutos han superado
con creces su objetivo inicial las
cuerdas permiten describir la gravedad a
escala cuántica y abren las puertas al
estudio de los agujeros negros han
permitido desarrollar múltiples áreas de
las Matemáticas y comprender mejor
ciertos aspectos del propio modelo
estándar
la teoría de cuerdas propone incluso
hipotéticas partículas candidatas como
las acciones para explicar
potencialmente la materia oscura
dicho esto aún queda mucho Por
investigar en particular los aspectos de
la teoría de cuerdas que mejor se
conocen se basan en las hipótesis de la
supersimetría la cual predice la
existencia a nuevas partículas que por
el momento no se han detectado existen
con participaciones que podrían explicar
por qué no se observan la supersimetría
pero siguen siendo muy poco comunes y
aún incomprendidas
por último para ir más lejos la teoría
es súper cuerdas existen realidad en
cinco versiones diferentes se puede
demostrar matemáticamente que estas
cinco teorías no son en realidad más que
aproximaciones a un único modelo aún más
completo
una teoría que describe un Universo de
11 dimensiones la teoría m
[Música]